mon meilleur souvenir à j'en ai
plusieurs là les premiers qui me
viennent j'irai le duplex avec jérôme
commandeur l'année dernière il était à
los angeles pour pour les oscars des
mémoires et c'est parti complètement en
cacahuète
bonjour à tous à tous
ils vont 180 attentats en un connard
vous avez des questions ou c'est juste
pour me faire perdre mon temps soeur m'a
dit que la batterie iv dire alors moi
aussi on m'a dit que c'était toi qui
avait un truc à me dis alors on se fait
chier en faire un duplex avec trois
personnes qui n'ont rien à se dire
aulas n'a pas été question cinéma
le deuxième gérant michel et la corde à
sauter et envoie ton pantalon tombe et
là on abat tous pu apprécier la
l'ampleur de ces deux à trous on a fait
une émission à propos de tmc bref et on
avait un invité à un monsieur qui énervé
après cyril qui était avancé accordé aux
leurs de mémoire il va encore reproché
d'avoir donné des astuces d'améliorer
les gens ils étaient venus très très
vénérés c'est à dire autant du
haut-plateau images d'un conseil parce
qu'après vous avez appelé toutes les
rédactions puisque je sais que parisien
était au four en long island et a mimé
redoux oui mais ils m'ont cherché un ami
parfait mais on a tous les deux voiliers
non mais je te lis il faut se calmer
mais on va se calmer on a mangé de la
scam et oui ça va donner un rein
compression longtemps alors il veut
faire le show devant les auxerrois sont
loin de faire le show et pensions que
c'était un peu restera ce moment là s'il
a assuré comme d'hab moi j'avais très
envie d'aller voir le mec de se barrer
comme quoi y'a des foules à dire non
mais d'accord mais là près de moi de
m'imposer à l'abri comme quoi mais non à
n'ont pas l'habitude de venir une fois
mon art on a dû tout annuler parce qu'on
avait trop de choses non j'abrège pas
mais ces gens d'annuler des meufs aussi
jordan mais je peux te dire la première
qui vient c'est eva longoria qui avaient
été droguées tihange sympa
voilà était vraiment parfaite on a pu
admirer en plus que si reed décidément
été très très bon et donc c'est
magnifique
et en plus ça l'a mis plein droit jean
michel mais ça faut pas bien ce qui fait
croire qu'elle la drague à brac de
bonheur doit-on boîte à bonheur what to
quality street
non magique très énervé qu'outre
histoire world war is burning étant bien
ma faveur oui tu dis tout le monde non
non non ok le marchand qui a chaque fois
qu'il vient se laisse pas démonter face
aux chroniqueurs vous disais ça
intéresse les jeunes apolitique non en
l'occurrence ça intéresse les jeunes qui
a couché avec qui ne sais pas ça dit ça
ballon mais ce genre d'animation que les
riches qui ce que je trouve non mepha
sur leur existence c'est pas pareil non
mais non non non non la brouille
vulgariser la chose non